we look at what's going on with Fox and
to a certain degree you have to wonder
who's next so having been thinking more
about what's going on with Fox and the
acquisition going on by Disney and and
I'll say what I've said the last few
times I brought it up
even though there was no reason that
that won't go through so far as we can
tell even if that does fall through Fox
is selling off its television and film
production it's doing that regardless
they were having a sale Disney is
currently looking to be the one who's
gonna buy but in many ways anyone who's
been watching the industry for a while
is go this was a surprise because it it
really didn't seem like if anybody was
gonna do this it was gonna be Sony
because Sony Sony first of all has not
actually been in film production for
that along Sony acquired Columbia
Pictures in 89 and it's not even 30
years they've been at this I mean you
want to compare that something like
Warner Brothers or Disney or universal
or even Fox that they're not even close
they they have not been at this for all
that long and their successes have been
kind of up and down that's not
necessarily atypical but you look at the
last few years it's been rough for Sony
now recently they did kind of reiterate
going no we're not selling our film
division we're gonna keep on powering on
I have to imagine that's probationary
though I really would have to think that
the the current heads of Sony Pictures
are being watched very carefully by the
heads of Sony as an overall corporation
because there are plenty of of the
divisions of Sony that are doing fine
electronics video games they've got
other areas they are they are doing just
fine and I think in many ways right now
the film division is a brick around the
neck of this company as a whole and if
it doesn't start pulling its own weight
I think they are going to cut it loose
but let me give a
context because I didn't I had felt this
but and I don't do research usually but
I really wanted to see if I could back
up this gut feeling that I had that that
Sony's there's a really good chance that
that Sony could start selling off these
assets in the next let's say five years
so I looked at again five years is a
good benchmark the last five years worth
of box office numbers for Sony now 2012
was a good year for them it was actually
their biggest year ever that was the
year that they had things like Skyfall
the amazing spider-man men in black 3
Hotel Transylvania 21 Jump Street that
was a good year for Sony and they've
been doing okay leading up to that 2013
was the first big drop down 34 percent
now to a certain degree you could chalk
that up to well we can't get sequels out
to the big sort of franchise sir' as we
got going last year we got to deal with
some other stuff they have their hits
they have been Miz's they kind of
they're breakevens that was kind of how
I broke stuff up now even when I use the
term breakeven or even what I say hits
or miss I need to find these terms a
little bit because trying to actually
figure out what is a hit and what is a
flop is all is actually almost
impossible because we don't actually
know how much gets spent on these movies
we know what the officially listed
production budget is but that's not the
full cost of the movie there depending
on how long it's been in production
they're often development costs if it's
been stalled multiple times that that
get that hour factor but don't get
listed in the production budget most of
these don't account for marketing which
can be anywhere from 1/2 to double the
production budget in some cases so
there's all that we don't know how these
much these things cost in the first
place but the hard and fast rule and I
do mean hard and fast sometimes this
rule is not enough to get you there but
it's the rule of thumb that I'm using is
if a film can double its production
budget then it
broken even so any film that I mentioned
going forward on these if I say that it
flopped it fell notably short of
doubling its production bargain budget
if I say broke even it doubled this
product you shouldn't budget within a
you know several million of that you
know within ballpark if it did notably
more than double its production budget
that's a hit again I don't want to
debate the specifics because honestly we
could have an argument over every single
one of these that I'm gonna bring out
but that that's just the general metric
and it and this is more about the
patterns and not the specific box-office
takes of any individual film I talked
about so please bear with me on that
as I said 2013 there was a drop but it
was also a bit of a mixed result and
sort of a recurring thing I'm gonna keep
coming back to it I think what Sony's
big problem is right now is they don't
have a stable franchise and they keep
trying to get one going and it's not
working out now some of the things that
they tried to get or even had as
franchises for a little while that kind
of had issues you're gonna see some of
them here so like some of the flops of
2013 included white house down
after earth Mortal Instruments City of
Bones bet you didn't even remember that
was a thing that happened and then carry
which was a big-budget horror remake
should have been a sure thing that only
broke even
Elysium which was Neill Blomkamp's big
follow-up to district 9 district I've
been nominated for an Oscar that only
broke even but they did still have some
promise Smurfs too got eviscerated by
critics but it that was a hit that made
decent money there Evil Dead remake
actually made good money this is the end
captain Phillips collided with a Chance
of Meatballs two grown ups to American
hustle all those were solid but the
thing is though really none of those
were mega hits they they were profitable
but none of them really on the scale
that Sony probably wanted certainly not
on the scale of the stuff they saw in
2012 which actually I think if they'd if
they'd had more of an eye for some mid
budget franchising they would have you
know maybe made a sequel to their Evil
Dead remake which as I said actually
made decent money but unfortunately and
this isn't unique to Sony the studio's
a lot of them seemed to have adopted
this we are in the tentpole business we
are not interested in mid budget decent
profits lower risk things they are going
all-in they want the maximum return
which means spending which first of all
means spending more money on these on
these projects in the first place which
makes them more important to be hits
each and every time but in addition to
that by eliminating a lot of these mid
tiers or it you know that the approach
that they've adapted opted is they look
at something like people dead which
again decent hit may just shy of 100
million on a 17 million dollar budget
really profitable but the thing is 100
just shy of a hundred million dollar box
office doesn't look impressive not when
you're looking at you know what Disney
and Warner Brothers are putting up in
the hundreds of millions of dollars you
know four hundred million dollars plus
or even Sony's own previous year before
they look at shy of a hundred million to
go well that wasn't what we wanted it's
not taking into account the fact that
they only spent seventeen million on it
so that was a tidy profit and yet
somehow we didn't get an Evil Dead
sequel now 2014 saw a very slight uptick
their total grosses were up about seven
percent from 2013 but still down 29
percent from 2012 and there were some
decent hits in here ranging from temples
to small stuff on the high end they had
the amazing spider-man 2 which honestly
underperformed for what they thought it
was gonna do but still did turn a decent
profit at least we think it did again we
don't know what they actually spent on
it but there was 22 Jump Street the
equalizer heaven is for real things like
a man - whiplash but then we get into
the evens and the flops and we start
seeing more franchise non-starters
Robocop they basically broke even on a
knee which maybe wasn't gonna be a
franchise starter but what was their big
go at a family musical that only broke
even
Pompeii their big disaster epic that was
a flop
even their oscar push Foxcatcher they
spent 24 million and made 12 2015 we are
down another
21% now 2015 was another decent but not
great year they still didn't even come
close to doing what they did in 2012 but
this was a year that saw some of their
major franchises have their actual
established successful franchises have
new entries so there was Spectre Hotel
Transylvania 2 paul blart mall cop 2
pixels not technically sequel but sony
was garnering a decent relationship with
Adam Sandler and those movies were
profitable but even these something
wasn't quite right you want to take a
look at Spectre which was their biggest
grosser that year and it did very well
but they spent 45 million dollars more
on it than they spent on Skyfall and
made 200 million dollars less with it
than they made with Skyfall they spent
more to make less then Neill Blomkamp
only managed to break-even again with
chappie and we get two more flops of
what we're intended to be awards
contenders with concussion Aloha so
right now the pattern that's emerging is
Sony is just not having any luck with
their awards chasee stuff they've kind
of they're starting to already abandon
their mid tier stuff that isn't already
somehow franchise material and I would
lump a Happy Madison productions in with
those even though like it's not like all
Adam Sandler produced films are in a
continuity with each other but that's a
pretty standard product your franchised
off of the brand and the vibe of what he
does then we get to the real low point
2016 2016 drops another 8% this is down
about 50% from 2012 this was their first
year where they failed to make a billion
dollars in box office receipts since
2005 and it was their lowest overall
year since 2001 this was the year of
Ghost Busters the Magnificent Seven
remake which they spent way too much
money on the brothers Grimsby Pride and
Prejudice and Zombies another young
adult a non-starter with the fifth wave
and even their hits weren't that big a
hit their biggest moneymaker that year
angry
birds and passengers and not even really
because that thing was stuck in
production development hell for so long
that the 100 million dollars they say
they spend on the official budget I
guarantee you that doesn't take into
account how much money they spent on
false starts for this thing you know you
had a couple of things in there yet
don't breathe yet sausage party but this
they had no major smash hits in 2016 and
they had multiple things that were
supposed to be and were intended to be
and we're supposed to have franchises
and didn't 2017 last year things got
slightly better up about 15% from 2016
but still down about 40 percent versus
2012 the big surprise hit Jumanji
welcome to the jungle which made a huge
money off of a reasonably contained a
budget Spiderman homecoming baby driver
Resident Evil the final chapter yeah
that was profitable the emoji movie
believe it or not but they also had a
fair number of missteps and some pretty
public ones with things like all the
money in the world
the Flatlanders remake rough night and
again some franchise non-starters or
some franchise should have been
continuing to live off of what had come
before and they kind of didn't and
that's where you find the Dark Tower
underworld blood war Smurfs The Lost
village which was actually profitable
but made almost 50% less than the
previous Mercer movie down both domestic
and foreign so what it seems like Sony
is dealing with right now is they are in
desperate need for at least three stable
profitable franchises and that word
stable is a big thing because the few
franchises that they have that are
reliable to semi reliable are just not
consistent
spider-man they've seen that blow up on
them already they had to get Marvel in
to come and help that and again amazing
spider-man 2 was profitable but it was
nowhere near what they were predicting
it to be and it was not stable enough to
launch all the stuff that they wanted to
launch off of that now they're kind of
doing what they did before they are
expecting to be able to bring
inch things off of it we've got the
venom movie coming out they're dipping
their toes a little more they were
planning a heck of a lot more off the
back of amazing spider-man 2 they seem
to be taking it slightly more one
project at a time here
but they're still trying to find ways to
look more of spider-man like I said they
have a decent thing going with Adam
Sandler but he's now moved on to Netflix
so they lost that Hotel Transylvania
might currently be their most stable
franchise but honestly the third one
looks kind of painful and I don't know
how much longer they'll be able to milk
that one presumes we'll probably get an
angry bird sequel we'll see what they
can do with that they have men in black
they haven't figure out what to do with
it since the third one one would think
James Bond could bring some stability
but there's two problems with that part
of the first thing is that they actually
don't control it completely it's partly
with MGM they're partnered on that which
means they don't see all the money from
those things anyways and the other thing
is the production cycle of those things
is way longer than it should be for a
major tentpole franchise at this point
the thing is you look at something like
Marvel or even DC which has been you
know they've been a mess with Warner
Brothers into the DC EU but they cranked
these things out at least one a year if
not two or three and you know that's
what you get from these you know big
stable franchises Star Wars we've been
getting one a year and all these things
James Bond we've been looking at four
year gaps between them with labored
productions the way that these things
seem to be made is just in a very older
mentality it's not a well-oiled machine
it's not reliable there's some stuff
that hasn't completely bombed for them
yet but it probably doesn't have much
gas left in the tank and that's your
Resident Evil's your underworlds your
Smurfs but right now sony has a
graveyard of failed franchise starters
Ghostbusters The Dark Tower the fifth
wave
Robocop Evil Dead Mortal Instruments and
again some of these even could have been
launched into something before whatever
reason Sony didn't move on the few that
could have made it and most of these
flat-out bombed you look at the other
major studios right now and
what they have going for them is
sustainable franchises several the ones
that are healthiest right now obviously
Disney Disney's got a cavalcade of the
things they've got Marvel they've got
Star Wars they've got Disney animation
they've got Pixar over at Warner
Brothers they've got all the Harry
Potter related stuff the DCU the Lego
branded movies they're kaiju versed
they're doing with the King Kong and
Godzilla thing and they're little
conjuring universe which is not setting
the box office on fire the way some of
this other stuff is but turning a nice
little profit even Universal which might
be in a similar boat to Sony at least
have has two mega reliable franchises
the despicably franchise and Fast and
the Furious those Universal could use
more and obviously they've got problems
to their whole dark universe collapse
and I might have to talk about Universal
in a separate video at some point in the
future I don't know about that but in
any case they've at least got those two
and actually I would go beyond just
despicable me illumination entertainment
has been massively reliable for
Universal even outside of Despicable Me
specifically all their films have turned
a solid profit sing secret life of pets
so they've got a stable could they got a
specific franchise as well as a stable
relationship with their animation
Department Sony animation has been up
and down plus Universal has Fast and the
Furious which they're now looking to
spin-offs for they're they're in a
better place franchise wise than Sony is
sony has spider-man which they are in
constant fear of losing because if they
don't keep cranking out films Marvel
gets the rights back but them having to
crank these things out at such a pace
increases the chances that they don't
work it's feasible that maybe they could
get something out of Jumanji like I said
that was a real big surprise hit last
year but there's also a distinct chance
that it was a fluke I just you know the
one runaway hit does not necessarily
translate to a franchise that I mean how
would you franchise it would you have it
be a completely different set of players
and characters and setting every single
time so that it's
like a Jumanji anthology kind of thing
or would you actually try and do a
direct sequel I haven't seen Jumanji
welcome to the jungle so I don't know
what the better call is but that seems
like a bit of a stretch
the thing is though if Sony doesn't net
it's only needs two things to happen
they need to net another to stable
reliable you know every two or three
year install they get a new installment
franchises they need those and they need
to have less high-profile flops because
that's I mean that is the thing you
don't necessarily have to have
everything make a ton of money as long
as there is an other stuff dragging you
down you either minimize your losses or
you increase your profits ideally both
and Sony really right now needs both and
like I said Sony is a company that could
sell off its film division you know they
were a big they bought their way into
this game in the first place they didn't
build a studio from the ground up they
bought Columbia and I mean I said maybe
there's something about Universal the
thing is though Universal is an
entertainment company that is what they
are so if they get rid of that they just
go away Sony is a lot more than just
making movies so they could look at what
Fox is doing and if this ultimately
works out well for Fox in terms of what
their goal is streamlining the things
that they believe that they dominate in
as opposed to can trying to continue to
play you know a blockbuster game against
companies that they made the
determination that they can't ever beat
like Warner Brothers like Disney they're
like you know what we're not even gonna
play that game anymore I bet you Sony is
really looking at them and and and we'll
be assessing over the next few years
whether or not that's a good call for
them to make I think the only thing that
that might save it beyond just getting
stable franchises is if they can
increase synergy across their divisions
because right now you know for the for
all the film
that they make and the fact that they
they have the PlayStation as a brand and
then they have their own video game
production studios there's not a lot of
synergized cross over there like the the
spider-man games that have been related
to the movies have been farmed out crap
it just seems like a real chance for
those divisions to build on top of each
other that they're not doing and so
maybe there's just should be more
integration if something like that
happens maybe they could feel like it's
buoying their other divisions and it's
worth keeping around but like I said
right now unless there's a major shift
and less Sony can stay well here's what
I would say unless they successfully
launched a series of spider-man
spin-offs that can sustain as their own
franchises or they managed to launch a
completely new franchise property or two
or three I don't see Sony still being in
this game within five years within three
even possibly I say give it once the
once the Fox acquisition is finalized
and everything transfers over to Disney
two years after that Sony will make its
calls to whether or not it's getting out
of this game and if things haven't
picked up getting gotten noticeably
better gotten back up to around where
things were in 2012 by then they're
gonna get out of this game at least
that's what I think is probably gonna
happen so those are my thoughts and my
overly long and detailed explanation got
I threw a lot of numbers see this is why
I don't do research I look up these
numbers in the way I need to go I need
to say the numbers because I went to the
trouble to looking them up I'm not sure
how much they actually actually needed
to get into specifics to the degree that
I did I don't even know if anybody cares
in any case what are your thoughts on
all this whatever they are drop
something on the comments let's talk
about it there's all the stuff to do
with likes and subscribes and patreon
support and buy a t-shirt and follow me
on Twitter listen to my podcast least
for all this stuff is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]